the various southern Germany traditions
run deep here in this picture postcard
land of mountains and meadows one of
those traditions is the beer garden the
perfect place to quench one's thirst and
many agree here the best remedy is a
wheat beer the most Bavarian of beers
a finish for you it's so refreshing much
better than other kinds of beer I think
wheat beer is more refreshing many of us
building decision refresh pretty sick
it's invigorating it's tasty and the
yeast makes you look good whether you
need it or not this is that a full man
champagne wheat beer is traditionally
served in a tall thin glass so the
bubbles have to travel further and it
takes longer for the beer to go flat
and there is also a special knack to
pouring it Georg Schneider's family has
been in the beer business for seven
generations who better to demonstrate
than him this week text is disclosed
test out before you pour you have to
rinse the glass then you open the bottle
and pour carefully holding the glass at
an angle let's do it when the last third
is still on the bottle you can decide
whether to drink the yeast or not it'll
be here for the by hub for the rumors
ooh mr. bear hug I'm gonna give you the
Baja pavilion basement if you want then
shake the bottle roll it with the palm
of your hand and then tip the yeast into
the glass with his claws and [ __ ]
schneider weisse in kiel hime nearly
ginsburg is the oldest wheat beer
brewery in bavaria in centuries past
bavarian Willers had a monopoly on the
industry and filled their coffers with
the profits but by the mid 19th century
quaddle fermented wheat beer was out of
fashion the original Georg Schneider
purchased a license to brew wheat beer
in 1872 he founded Schneider visa and
restored the drinks popularity some call
him wheat beers Savior when my
great-great-great grandfather who
founded the company believed in the
quality of the beer he said if it's made
well enough it will always find friends
but it took nearly 100 years for wheat
beer to make a major comeback today it's
synonymous with Bavaria and increasingly
popular in export markets
historian Carl gutting ER has written a
book about the regional tradition he
says Bavaria almost went down a
completely different path well help me
by Yau in earlier times Bavarians mostly
drank wine we mustn't forget Bavarians
were mainly wine drinkers yes 30
sustained hates keyboard phone then came
the purity law in 15 16 and that might
be a good enough to become mass-produced
I masson Dawkins he hadn't saucony the
rest is history but the age-old question
remains what goes best with a wheat beer
a pork knuckle roast pork or perhaps a
plate of cheese spaetzle locals will
tell you there's nothing better than a
traditional Bavarian breakfast of veal
sausages pretzels and a good dollop of
sweet mustard wheat beers often referred
to as the bavarian cappuccino
by own device bavaria without wheat beer
could you imagine bavaria without the
mountains or oktoberfest no it belongs
here a wheat beer is the heart of
bavaria so it's bavaria in a beverage
and like the locals wheat beer comes in
all shapes sizes and colors the
quintessential drink for the southern
german summer